[Music]
what is grief
if not love
persevering
part of the madness of the multiverse is
we get to see different realities and we
see different versions primarily of
doctor strange but we do see other
versions of wanda maximov
i think one division was this journey of
her for the first time taking her own
life into her own hands and it was fun
transitioning from her experience to
this movie you could use an avenger
there are other avengers i'll get you
back on the lunch box
what do you know about the multiverse
we wanted to satisfy the one division
fans
and take them to the next level with a
character they loved
it was fun just looking at it from a
different perspective
the multiverse
this had his theories
he believed it was dangerous
we need your help
it's magical she owns that character so
well it's a very powerful performance
with a very powerful character
in the multiverse there are alternative
versions of everyone it gives the
characters unique opportunity to meet
themselves
to recognize qualities that they may
have been blind you
the fate of the multiverse depends on us
[Music]
stephen strange
the illuminati will see you now
we will see what kind of doctor strange
you are marvel studios doctor strange
videopg 13.